the brutal attacks against ukrainian
citizens have horrified the world
the biden administration says it is
working with its allies to put russian
president vladimir putin on trial
ukraine has set up an online archive to
document the atrocities these are war
crimes these are shocking and brutal
acts that are completely unacceptable
and the united states will work with the
international community to make sure
there's accountability cell phones are
recording the brutality that has gone
beyond the usual boundaries of war
attacks on civilian targets allegations
of rape torture and extreme deprivation
all can constitute war crimes or crimes
against humanity captured russian
soldiers are reportedly saying they were
told to bomb civilian areas even handing
over maps we filed all the criminal
charges in the international court we
have the criminal cases opened in
ukraine more than 4 000 of individual
criminal cases already by the prosecutor
general we have 10 more countries that
open their own
individual criminal prosecutions and
we're providing all the evidence to them
along with putin ukraine officials are
vowing to prosecute soldiers and
military commanders both on the ground
and in russia international war crimes
investigators are in ukraine risking
their own lives to defend those whose
lives were savagely taken experts warn
evidence gathering is a slow task people
should be prepared for some time and the
complexity of the process that this is
not going to be immediate
and this is not going to be easy
no sitting head of state has ever been
tried for war crimes finding and
arresting a heavily protected vladimir
putin won't be easy but in-person
prosecution is required by international
law vladimir putin needs to be charged
and go to justice
or die with an indictment hanging over
his head
russia has repeatedly denied it has
committed any war crimes but the
evidence has been overwhelming and
broadcast all over the world
images that have haunted millions and
galvanized leaders from the u.s canada
and their allies to make putin pay
jennifer johnson global news washington